good morning John morning I woke up and
I took a shower and I brushed my teeth
and I did it all in my normal house with
my normal stuff and it's sometimes we
feel like we got to do thoughts from
places from really weird places but
maybe we can just find some really weird
places in the places where we live I'm
here with Michael say hi good morning
John we are driving to one of the
coolest places I have ever found in
Mizzou and some of you may be a little
bit grossed out you don't like dead
things you might not what about this
video still driving this is the Philip L
Roache new logic museum and this is
Emily and she's going to give us a tour
hi in this tiny room alone we have about
21 thousand specimens Museum 7,000 bird
specimens they're on sticks so you can
pick them up or down sticks how do you
keep them preserved the ones dating
before a 1960s were preserved with arson
highly effective for preserving the
birds not highly effective for
preserving the curators there you gotta
walk around with two of these on your
head think it's about 40 pounds to carry
these on your head and they grow more
every year so you get older and older
well I guess you get used to it I guess
they kind of grow on ya people who have
a loose understanding of animal skulls
what they think it isn't they're like
it's a bear no it's a dog no it's a cat
no it's a bear dog cat the bear dog cat
you can also tell that this guy probably
scavenged a lot and eats a lot of bones
and that kind of thing teeth are worn a
lot of these guys get dental abscesses
this is like has a huge exposure of root
right there where they had bone loss so
they'll get food impacted in their teeth
and they can't go to the dentist and
they get to throw out and all kinds of
fun nasty gross things make them angry
what's the stinkiest place in here the
stinkiest cabinet is probably the bald
eagle it's really hard to remove all of
the grease from the skin of an aquatic
bird cuz they have all that fat so the
snow like the boobies smell pretty bad
it tends to creep people out Oh cause
it's like little baby skulls it's almost
like we evolved from them
I saw how many places Montana can you
touch a monkey it is an echidna you have
more teeth than any other mammal
Catherine used to work at a wildlife
rehab place so she has worked a lot with
opossums and their babies they are
adorable the fringy old palate of a
freshwater drum fish I posted this on
tumblr I got a lot of private messages
from people being like I need I can't
sleep at night I need to know what it is
very concerned this is what we call the
cold room because it's cold there's a
beaver - which I love he's huge I like
how you're holding him like a baby say
hey yeah I touched a beaver I've got a
lot of thoughts about this place about
how it largely exists to satisfy that
wonderful and satiable human curiosity
about how this and other amazing places
like it are tremendously under supported
it could not exist without the help of
like full-time volunteers like Emily and
the pier density of amazing and awesome
and interesting things in this place
rivals anywhere I've ever been in my
life and yet it's hiding there unknown
before most of the people even though
it's open to the public by appointment
but mostly they thought that I can't get
out of my mind is that I'm glad that it
exists I'm glad that it is a place and
I'm glad that it's there thank you to
Emily for the tour and thank you to all
people who helped support that place and
places like it John congratulations on
all of the best book of the year lists
that you're on right now as soon as I
read it I knew that it was but I'm glad
all of the rest of the world agrees with
me - and I'll see you on Tuesday